what just one big play I've got in man
that's a big Python
he's back in the hole let me get the
head can you go over there to the shell
of the water
thank you you still getting by the tail
yes I've got enough be careful it's
really deep it's deep bottom here now
talk about having a tiger by the tail we
got a giant Python by the tail and like
waist deep bag water
I'm very dangerous we don't know have
you turn as it has been alleged don't
let him know what it's got a bit home
told I'm here here I can see him I can
see you you got it go let's go
I'm gonna go in the crack after him you
got him I've got him I stay here over my
shoulder right here over my shoulder you
can see him way up in there don't let go
don't look over there
right here will the no stand by you've
got a good she's got a good grip I know
okay I'm going I'm going in that
slippery
here's my bag you got him you got him
I'm good I've got him see what happens
you just bit the rock be careful it's
got a mouthful of teeth I've got him by
the head oh he's out he's loose I'm
gonna you don't worry whoa-oh-oh-oh here
here comes the head here comes here
watch he won't bite you watch it yes
don't worry
he sees hidden me where's his head wait
ladies here waiting Fela brainy I'm
feeling a bad page rank when you buy
going like it all the worse it is now
okay where's his head I've just got part
of his buddy wait wait wait
I got a bad bite oh this is head no
Crabbie's head it's right here I got a
bad body swagger he'll be I feel like I
gotta give out his stuff in his head
back I'm gonna say had a bad bite
where's his head where's his head then I
got a bad bite to the leg where's this
head over here you know like I'm feeling
man just down for that fence
yeah I got a bad bite okay I got a big
open wound and all this all this
festival oh man he bit me really I'm
gonna try and move slowly towards no no
way I just don't want to be bitten again
I really they had bosey still grabbing
you know it went okay he's nervous I
said just among just possession just
Patel he's planning something yes
something is going on like that he's
planning something he's squeezing me
very tightly I'll tell you what I'm
gonna take the killing over there I've
got a really bad late for my way I gave
this to this one this direction what is
he worries running right worries in my
right leg man my letterhead killing me
he must take back soon
I've got a really gotta get home I got
to get out of this stuff I mean I'm
bleeding I'm gonna take the tail the
head will come out behind me summer
and white you stood about the grip is it
good enough no no no I've just got the
very tip week oh yeah bad boy he's
behind me somewhere man I can't see him
now I can head out check the house I
gotta get out of that we gotta take care
of this wound okay well just give me
whoa